-Hello!
-19 seasons!
-Can you believe it?
-Congratulations.
That´s really something.
-It really is.
-Yeah, it´s an accomplishment
beyond, I feel like,
what anyone else can talk about,
so congratulations.
-Thank you.
And it´s 19 seasons,
and I´m in and happy.
-Good. Yeah.
-That´s what´s amazing!
-Yeah, that really is.
One of the things
that´s very exciting,
and I imagine one of the things
that keeps it fresh
for you guys who are in the cast
is you have
amazing guests stars.
-Amazing.
-So, they come in.
You get to work
with different people
over the course of 19 seasons.
Brooke Shields.
-Brooke Shields.
-Brooke Shields. And this
is your recommendation, yes?
-It was.
You know, I was at -- Another
friend of ours, Ali Wentworth,
has this fantastic show,
and we were at a screening,
and Brooke was the guest star
and was so brilliant
and so dark and so funny.
And so...funny.
ANd so funny. [ Chuckles ]
-Yeah.
-And, um -- And so beautiful
and so powerful and so funny.
-And when you watch "S.V.U.,"
you´re always looking
for a funny person, yeah.
-You know I love the funny.
-Yeah.
-And so, um, when I saw her, I
thought, like, [gasps] "She´s
it."
Because we had this character in
mind to come, you know...
stir it up.
-Well, that clip actually
sort of introduces her.
-Oh, that´s her, and she´s
a buzzkill for Olivia Benson,
let me tell you.
-Yeah, but she´s a grandmother,
as you set up --
-And that´s how I pitched her.
-Yeah.
So, you had to say
to Brooke Shields,
"I want you to come and be
a grandmother on my show."
-But it was so funny.
-Brooke Shields.
The Brook Shields.
-No, not that one.
ANother one.
-Oh, okay. Gotcha.
-No, but we were sitting there,
and I said, "Listen.
There´s an amazing part.
Would you ever consider doing
an arc on the show?"
And she said, "Oh, wow.
Are you serious?"
I said, "Yeah,"
and then I pitch her.
I said, "This incredible
powerful woman.
She comes and da-da-da,
and she´s the grandmother."
And she goes "[Laughs]
I´m sorry, what?"
I said, "No, no,
it´s a grandmother."
And then even I heard it.
I was like, "Oh, no, no, no.
It´s not like that."
But she was like,
"I see how you are."
-Oh, yeah.
-"Oh, pitch the show,
and then go, ´Grandma.´"
So, on the first day
of her shooting,
I redid the sides,
which are the pages that you get
when -- you know,
to learn your lines.
-The script pages, sure.
-Script pages.
And so it said --
It said, "Ellie Porter,"
you know, whatever, 40s --
and I had it say,
"Ellie Porter, early 70s."
[ Laughter ]
In the description.
And then I did it the next day,
I said, "early 30s."
-Oh, that´s very nice.
-So, you know --
-You won her back.
-You give, you take,
you do it all.
-Your husband
is also on the show,
plays your lawyer on the show.
-Yes.
-And he´s also --
-Sexy, sexy.
Tall drink of water.
-Sexy lawyer. Yeah!
And he´s also on
a fantastic show, "Younger."
-Amazing show!
-And now, because, again, you´re
obviously very recognizable,
haven´t been on a show
for as many years as you are,
but you guys were on vacation
and now --
and now your husband, Peter´s,
getting some attention.
-Well, people are
changing their tune.
-Yeah.
-And we were in Italy
this summer
in a little gelateria,
and we all of a sudden
could feel a group of women
coming over.
And so Peter
sort of knows the drill.
And so he -- You know,
he´s like,
"Okay, they´re coming.
Whatever."
So he sort of grabs the camera,
and the woman goes --
-Because he thinks
he´s going to take
a picture of them with you.
-He does.
-Yeah.
-Until she says, "No, no, no,
I love you.
You´re ´Younger,´ sí?"
And then she takes the camera,
and she goes,
"Please,
for the taking picture."
I said, "Absolutely."
I´m sitting there, and then all
these Italian women
are handing me their phones,
and I´m like,
"Okay. More light.
Face the light.
Okay, you guys
look great, smile.
Peter, put your arm around her."
-That´s great.
-It was very fun.
-It´s Peter´s time!
I love it!
-It is.
The women are elbowing me
out of the way now.
-To be on a show
that Italian women watch,
that´s the jackpot.
-Oh, they are not -- and
they´re like,
"Oh, Peter, I am Team Charles."
[ Laughter ]
I´m like,
"Easy there, easy lady."